alles ist im körper drin nichts hängt
außen draußen irgendwie raus
er muss durch die haut sich die puppe
schnappen und da mehrfach drauf drücken
und dann sieht man wie das die sich die
zylinder jetzt hier füllen und dann tobt
das so lange bis die die ausreichende
füllung und härte damit erreicht habe
ich selber keine praktisch gar nicht
mehr klicken so richtig schön fest der
jüngste patient den ich selber
implantierter war 24 jahre alt
der hatte eine vollständige
erektionsstörung durch eine
querschnittslähmung bei machen nach
einem skiunfall der älteste patient war
86 jahre alt der kampf zwischen und
erzählt dass er eine solche these hat
die kaputt gegangen war
die war hat durch nutzung aufgebraucht
wir wollten neue haben und habe ich ihn
gefragt mit 86 musste das noch sagen na
ja
[Musik]